et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien Chenu bonjour merci d'être
avec nous député du Nord vice-président
du rassemblement national vice-président
de l'Assemblée nationale en étant
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour
puisqu'après le Sénat la Cour des
comptes a remis son rapport hier sur les
recours au cabinet de conseil la Cour
des comptes qui disent que disait la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale un
recours inapproprié des dérives sous la
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron ils
estiment certains recours inappropriés
je le disais est-ce que il faut revoir
ce recours au cabinet de conseils pour
vous oui une augmentation absolument
incroyable entre les chiffres qu'on
avait je crois en 2014 où il y a elles
peuvent à peu près dans le budget de
l'État un recours pour 11 millions
d'euros cabinet de conseils on est passé
à 233 millions d'euros si on ne compte
même pas le recours au cabinet de
conseil pour j'allais dire la gestion du
parc informatique ou des techniques
informatiques qui fait bondir je crois
après de 9 millions d'euros donc on voit
bien que même si c'est faible par
rapport au budget de l'État à l'ensemble
du budget de l'État il y a une mauvaise
habitude qui s'est installée et je pense
que celle-ci qui consiste finalement à
mettre le cerveau des politiques entre
les mains du privé c'est-à-dire avec ce
que ça suicide de l'absence de
transparence d'absence de contrôle etc
est un est une pente dangereuse mais la
macronie c'est ça c'est à dire ce sont
des gens qui comme ils n'ont pas de
conviction sans remettre à des pseudos
experts qui leur disent techniquement
voilà il faut mettre plus ceci moins de
cela etc or la politique c'est pas ça la
politique c'est avoir des convictions
avoir une vision et les cabinets de
conseils si tenter qu'on puisse de temps
en temps faire appel à eux ne peuvent
être là qu'en accompagnant techniquement
des gens qui ont une vision politique la
macronie n'a aucune vision politique ce
sont des gens qui ont des visions
comptables des choses bien sûr plus bien
entendu j'allais dire le copinage du
système car tous ces cabinets de
conseils sont d'anciens
d'anciennes personnes qui sont issues de
cabinet ministériel c'est le système qui
alimente le système sur le dos des
Français le Sénat a adopté une
proposition de loi c'était en octobre
dernier suite à la commission d'enquête
sénatoriales sauf que l'Assemblée
nationale ne semble jamais emparée
est-ce que vous demandez à l'Assemblée
nationale de s'emparer de ce texte oui
bien sûr il le faut il faut qu'on puisse
mettre en place des pratiques qui soient
transparentes qui explique aussi quel
est le rôle de notre haute
administration on a une haute
administration qui sait très bien faire
son boulot qui sait très bien faire ce
boulot mais il faut aussi empêcher
d'aller pantoufler dans le privé
lorsqu'on est au fonctionnaires moi je
pense qu'il faut que ce soit beaucoup
plus étanche il est pas compréhensible
que lorsque on devient haut
fonctionnaire et bien immédiatement
après on a y pantouflé pendant des
années dans le privé pour gagner de très
très hauts salaires qu'on se retrouve ce
texte soit dans l'agenda de l'assemblée
qui fixe l'agenda de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est bien le gouvernement
donc c'est au gouvernement est
d'accepter
vous laissez nous pencher sur ces
dérives qui sont des dérives dramatiques
du pouvoir rappelez-vous lorsqu'elle
Macron est arrivé au pouvoir il devait
laver plus blanc ça allait être le
nouveau monde fin des mauvaises
pratiques ils ont fait le pire du
possible ils ont rendu le système
politique
inefficace ils l'ont rendu extrêmement
opaque et je pense que les Français le
voient ils concourent en cela éloigner
les Français évidemment des urnes la
macronie a fait pire que tous les autres
systèmes politiques depuis tant d'années
autre sujet on a vu samedi des députés
nupesses défilés en fait à Paris
participer à une manifestation interdite
défiler en écharpe au milieu de gens qui
criaient tout le monde détestent la
police qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous savez ce que j'en pense c'est
facile moi je trouve ça honteux d'abord
c'est une manifestation interdite donc
difficile pour un député qui participe
avec son écharpe à une magnifique une
manifestation interdite dans suite faire
la leçon à la terre entière et de dire
qu'il faut respecter la loi il faudrait
il faudrait les sanctionner moi je veux
pas rentrer là-dedans parce que je pense
que ça met en lumière ce que sont ces
individus et leur rapport au pouvoir la
sanction je vais vous dire elle viendra
par les urnes les Français voient qui
sont Sandrine Rousseau qui sont les gens
de l'aide les filles avec qui le
défilent ce qu'il pense et les valeurs
auxquelles ils sont attachés ça sert à
rien d'essayer de sanctionner des
parlementaires moi je suis très attaché
à la liberté des parlementaires y
compris lorsqu'elle me gêne lorsqu'elle
me heurte mais ce sont les Français qui
vont les sanctionner parce qu'ils ne
sont plus dans ce qu'on appelle
effectivement
l'arc républicain en réalité il ne
défende pas les valeurs de la République
puisqu'ils attaquent nos institutions
l'institution de la police quand Marine
Le Pen dit la France insoumise a choisi
de rompre avec la République vous
adhérez totalement oui bien sûr c'est la
France incendiaire Jordan Bardella avait
trouvé cette expression qui est très
claire quand on reprise d'ailleurs oui
mais ça veut dire que c'est une
expression qui vise juste quand ce sont
des députés qui manifestent à côté de
gens qui hurlent la police tue je
rappelle que la police est une
institution de la République une
institution contrôlée une institution
qui peut s'améliorer il y a pas de
problème à ça notamment dans la
formation moi j'entendais les syndicats
de police qui demandent à être eux-mêmes
mieux formés mais c'est une de nos
institutions et en fait la France
insoumise donne des coups de boutoir à
chaque fois dans les institutions de
notre pays ça veut dire mais Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'avait dit il avait dit à bas
la mauvaise République ce qui veut dire
ABA la République il a qualifie de
mauvaise mais ça veut dire qu'il ne se
situe pas dans cette sphère des lieux
qui respectent les valeurs de la
République en tapant comme ils le font
matin midi et soir sur nos institutions
ces élus d'extrême gauche et colos et
bien dévoile leur vrai visage et c'est
bien que les Français les voient parce
qu'il y a des gens qui de bonne foi
votent pour eux et bien ils se rendent
compte aujourd'hui que ces gens n'ont
qu'une obsession c'est déconstruire la
République la Cinquième République en
tous les cas et les valeurs qui nous
donnent encore un peu de solidité parmi
les députés présents il y a Éric
Coquerel est-ce qu'il peut rester
président de la commission des finances
c'est un autre débat
Eric Coquerel est président de la
commission des finances parce que cette
commission échoua à un membre de
l'opposition alors au moment de
l'élection on aurait pu imaginer que ça
revienne d'ailleurs à un député du
rassemblement national bon les histoires
j'allais dire les tambousis
politiciennes ont amené Éric Coquerel à
devenir président moi je ne mélange pas
les choses je condamne fermement
Eric Coquerel lorsqu'il défilent aux
côtés de gens de la famille Traoré qui
sont des voyous qui sont des gens
multicondés qui sont des gens
infréquentables je trouve que c'est
piteux de le voir défiler il avait pas
l'air très à l'aise d'ailleurs
d'entendre les cris de tout le monde
déteste la police mais à côté de ça je
ne le confond pas lorsqu'il est
président de la commission des finances
je pense qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
ericoquerel représente l'opposition à ce
titre il a été élu président de la
commission des finances si on pouvait
essayer d'avoir un peu de stabilité dans
ce qu'il reste d'institutions solides
dans notre pays notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale tout le monde en serait
gagnant donc
poste
le poste était remis en jeu on
présenterait probablement un candidat
parce qu'on l'a toujours fait mais de
toute façon cette présidence de
commission des finances doit aller un
membre de l'opposition et ce n'est pas à
la macronie de choisir le membre de
l'opposition c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe dans une démocratie la majorité
ne choisit pas son opposition ce sont
les Français les Français ont choisi
premier groupe d'opposition le
rassemblement national nous devons donc
assumer un maximum de responsabilités
après les émeutes le gouvernement va
présenter une loi en conseil des
ministres pour accélérer la
reconstruction vous votre respect
c'est tellement faible enfin on en fera
peut-être pas l'économie c'est à dire
que il y a pas de raison qu'on ne la
vote pas mais enfin quand madame borne
nous dit je vais faire des diagnostics
en faire une loi pour reconstruire des
écoles des mairies etc très bien mais
enfin en solutionne pas le problème
madame borne et l'ensemble de ceux qui
nous gouvernent depuis 30 ou 40 ans mais
ce qui nous gouverne aujourd'hui était
déjà aux manettes il y a 5 ans il y a 10
ans il y a 15 ans ce sont les mêmes ils
ont mis juste un coup de peinture en
s'appelant macroniste mais ce sont les
mêmes ont une immense responsabilité
c'est la faillite non seulement la
politique de la ville 100 milliards
dépensés sur 20 ans mais c'est surtout
l'affaissement des autorités dans notre
pays l'autorité de l'État l'autorité de
l'État à l'école l'autorité de l'État
dans la justice et dans la réponse
pénale et puis il faut bien voir qu'on a
face à soi des émeutiers qui tapent
déconstruisent abîmes ce qui fait
symbole de la France c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il brûle une école en fait
derrière ils ATT la laïcité lorsqu'il
brûle un théâtre ça a été le cas dans ma
commune à Denain c'est derrière la
France de la culture la France des
Lumières lorsqu'il brûle lorsqu'ils
attaquent pardon le bar gay de Nantes
c'est une façon de refuser la façon dont
on amené en France à vivre libre comme
on a envie de vivre et bien en fait il
s'attaque à la façon de vivre à la
française mais la réponse la plus
adaptée c'est quoi quand Marine Le Pen
estime qu'il faut une réponse plus ferme
de la part de la justice ça veut dire
quoi précisément c'est quoi elle est
évidemment pénale la réponse la plus
adaptée d'abord c'est la plus adaptée
avant avant une réponse sociale avant la
réponse sociale ça fait 30 ans qu'on a
ça fait 30 ans votre réponse à vous
c'est d'abord une réponse pénale elle
est d'abord sous quelle forme ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on évacue un traitement
social qui peut être nécessaire dans
certains cas mais elle est d'abord dans
la peine et dans la sanction que doivent
encourir ou plancher par exemple ce sont
les penchées c'est aussi ça fonctionnait
pas c'est un retour aux peines plancher
non mais mais c'est pas seulement un
retour en pleine branché et pas le
plancher c'est un des dispositifs en
fait la pénale c'est une multiplicité de
dispositifs pour permettre d'avoir une
réponse adaptée et surtout immédiate et
cohérente moi j'ai déposé avec les
députés du rassemblement national une
proposition de loi pour revenir sur
l'excuse de minorité pour que les
mineurs de très à 16 ans et bien et les
mêmes sanctions en cours les mêmes
sanctions je pense que ça fait partie du
jeu un Jordan Bardella et Marine Le Pen
ont expliqué que il n'a jamais tenté le
fait de sanctionner les familles à
travers la suppression d'allocations
familiales dont le gamin serait
multirécidiviste n'importe quel parent
sensé d'où qu'il vienne français oui
immigré d'ailleurs il y a pas il y a pas
d'histoire n'a pas et n'a pas vocation à
voir son gamin de 13-14 ans la nuit
brûler des écoles il doit être
évidemment
les républicains je rappelle ils ont été
au pouvoir combien d'années moi je
rappelle que c'est sous Nicolas Sarkozy
que par exemple les forces de l'ordre
ont le plus diminué donc parler comme le
rassemblement national lorsque vous êtes
dans l'opposition pour gouverner comme
les pires des socialistes lorsque dans
la majorité ça c'est le discours
habituel des républicains ils n'ont ni
la volonté ni la solidité ni le courage
politique pour le faire parce qu'en fait
son prisonnier d'un système dans lequel
il renvoie en permanence les ascenseurs
à ceux qui ont gouverné avant eux donc
nous nous avons des propositions sur la
majorité pénale l'abaissement de la
majorité pénale excuse de minorité les
peines plancher oui il y a tout un
dispositif tout un arsenal il est
multiple mais oui c'est une réponse de
la fermeté il faut reprendre le contrôle
parce que sinon la prochaine fois ce
sera pas
nous n'aurons pas les mêmes difficultés
nous aurons bien pire je l'ai dit
Elisabeth borne votre responsabilité est
immense dans la gestion passée mais si
vous ne solutionnez pas si vous
n'entreprenez pas une politique une qui
soit celle de la fermeté une réponse
ferme et bien la prochaine fois ce sera
pire que ça répondu rien parce que
Isabelle borne est un encéphalogramme
plat elle ne répond pas c'est une
machine il n'y a pas de conviction il y
a pas de chair elle applique doctement
mécaniquement ce que demande le
président de la République mais elle ne
pense rien et Elisabeth borne il y a
également la suppression du droit du sol
qui suggéré par Marine Le Pen et ce qui
suppose que les émeutes principalement
le fait d'enfants immigrés en même temps
c'est pas ce qu'a dit Gérald Darmanin
face au sénateur à la semaine dernière
dit beaucoup de bêtises et il a dit il
dit beaucoup de bêtises
par exemple il disait que la police
était recrutée parmi les enfants sans
diplôme donc c'est une énorme bêtise
d'abord parce que lorsqu'on est officier
c'est bac + 3 c'est
inutilement blessant vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre qui sincèrement n'ont
pas besoin de ça sur la problématique
migratoire
qui ont ou qui n'ont pas la nationalité
française et une minorité de gens qui
n'ont pas la nationalité française
est-ce que derrière ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut tourner la tête et se dire
qu'il n'y a pas un problème avec
l'immigration dans notre pays et qui
lorsqu'elle est incontrôlée lorsqu'elle
a accueilli tellement de gens
lorsqu'elles continuent à cuire
tellement de gens elle ne produit pas
une catastrophe évidemment qui a
problème évidemment qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a des jeunes gens qui sont
français mais qui ne se sentent pas
français mais qui considère je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'en allant caillasser
une école
amusée une médiathèque un bar etc refuse
les valeurs que véhicule la société
française parce que vous le dites ils
sont français d'abord un moratoire sur
l'immigration si vous pouvez déjà ne pas
ajouter
prenons les choses j'allais dire avec
logique d'abord arrêtons d'ajouter des
couches de difficultés aux difficultés
que nous avons un moratoire sur
l'immigration arrêtons l'immigration
incontrôlée dans notre pays ensuite à
qu'il soit français ou pas s'ils sont
pas français s'ils sont étrangers et
qu'ils sont récidivistes ou qu'il
commettent des actes délictueux la
réponse c'est l'exclusion ils doivent
repartir d'où ils viennent s'ils ne sont
pas français ils ont donc une
nationalité d'un autre pays qui serait
amené à devoir les accueillir on renvoie
les étrangers qui se comportent mal sur
notre sol ça c'est aussi un principe de
base des pays qui n'en veulent pas alors
ça ne se fait pas en deux jours il faut
entreprendre des négociations avec des
pays par exemple l'Algérie qui était qui
est dans les pays qui nous envoient le
plus en nombre et en pourcentage de
population immigrées c'est un pays avec
lequel on doit revoir nos accords
notamment
1968 là encore Edouard Philippe lorsque
il a reçu le président teboune les
républicains lorsqu'ils ont été au
gouvernement mais jamais ils ont ouvert
ce dossier là à aucun moment ils n'ont
ouvert ce dossier là le responsabilité
est immense donc vous voyez il y a des
pays avec lesquels il faut reprendre un
dialogue pour qu'il reprenne leur
délinquants et puis il y a ceux qui en
étant français ne se sentent pas
français et bien pour eux effectivement
et la réponse pénale doit être ferme des
centres éducatifs fermés des courte
peines des réponses adaptées mais
surtout immédiates parce qu'on voit bien
que des émeutiers et moi c'était la
police je me souviens de Denain et de
Valenciennes qui me disait lorsque je
suis allé les visiter la semaine des
émeutes qui me disait les émeutiers les
qui ont été arrêtés le mercredi était
déjà de retour dans le quartier le
samedi donc c'est absolument
insoutenable pour les forces de l'ordre
et pour les habitants parce que je
rappelle que les premiers victimes de
tous ces violences c'est les habitants
des quartiers populaires français et
immigrés d'ailleurs c'est eux qui
subissent tout ça et qui n'ont pas envie
d'être associés à ces voyous et puis un
dernier pack nous n'avons pas évoqué
c'est celui de la lutte contre la drogue
Gérald Darmanin il y a un an dizaine
nous allons fermer tous les points de
deal en France écoutez ça donnerait le
sourire si c'était pas aussi grave moi
je suis pour qu'on ait une réponse
beaucoup plus forte sur les
consommateurs de drogue notamment sur
cette espèce de bienveillance qu'il y a
dans un système
parisien qui consiste à détourner le
regard sur celui qui fume du shit sur
celui qui consomme de la cocaïne et qui
en réalité alimente grandement le
commerce de la drogue moi je suis
favorable pour qu'on tape très fort les
consommateurs
vous dites que vous êtes allé à Denain
pendant les émeutes chaque semaine
Marine Le Pen s'est faite plutôt rare
pendant pendant la séquence elle va elle
doit se rendre à Beauvais demain pour
rencontrer les commerçants du
centre-ville qu'est-ce qu'elle va leur
dire pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a été aussi
longtemps sur la réserve mais d'abord
vous savez notre rôle n'est pas
d'ajouter
des cris de l'attention un pays qui en a
déjà beaucoup donc Marine Le Pen a fait
preuve d'une immense responsabilité
elle a des solutions elle est présentera
demain au commerçants de Beauvais
rencontrera elle va expliquer quelle est
sa logique celle dont je vous ai parlé
celle de la réponse pénale celle du
soutien au PME lorsqu'elles sont mises
dans la difficulté elle va leur
expliquer sa façon aussi la façon
qu'elle aurait de gouverner son mode de
gouvernance de la France si demain elle
était élue qui serait probablement assez
différente celui d'Emmanuel Macron et
puis je pense que je voulais dire notre
notre but notre rôle c'est pas d'ajouter
du bazar on l'a vu quand la France
insoumise n'appelle pas au calme et bien
nous parce que nous sommes des élus
républicains
responsable et bien nous considérons que
oui nous appelons au calme à soutenir
les forces de l'ordre à l'apaisement au
retour de la paix civile et Marine Le
Pen à travers sa posture à travers sa
position publique et bien est dans cette
logique d'un retour à l'apaisement notre
pays un fort besoin d'apaisement les
Français ont été fortement perturbés
abîmé traumatisé par la réforme des
retraites les voilà qui doivent payer
dans leur quartier dans leur quotidien
les émeutes notre pays a besoin
d'apaisement on est loin des 100 jours
d'apaisement alors justement on arrive
au bout des 100 jours on parlait
d'abaissement est-ce que vous considérez
qui Emmanuel Macron doit prendre la
parole à l'issue de cette période et si
oui sous quelle forme pour dire quoi le
président de la République est
totalement dépassé en réalité ça sert il
peut s'exprimer mais le problème c'est
que sa parole est très décrédibiliser
pourquoi d'abord il ne sait que rarement
trop rarement intéressé au sujet dit du
régalien c'est à dire de la sécurité
faisant de la République lui il aime
bien l'international il aime l'économie
avec les succès qu'on connaît sur les
deux plans d'ailleurs je dis ça de façon
ironique mais il a toujours trouvé que
les sujets de la sécurité
de la justice etc était finalement des
sujets d'intendance ils ne sont jamais
vraiment préoccupés et d'ailleurs il n'a
pas de doctrine intellectuelle sur ces
sujets là et donc aujourd'hui il est
dépassé quand on entend Emmanuel Macron
dire qui avait pu prévoir ça bah nous
nous les élus du rassemblement national
depuis des années nous mettons en garde
la société politique sur le problème
migratoire sur l'insécurité sur les
crises des banlieues sur ce que vivent
les Français le pouvoir d'achat
évidemment mais à chaque fois que nous
avons fait des propositions ils les ont
refusé je vous rappelle que les peines
planchers c'est revenu il y a 6 mois à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça a été porté
par qui par une députée de la majorité
la vice-présidente de l'Assemblée
n'avait muchu qui a voté contre c'est
les députés de la majorité qui ont
refusé les peines plancher portées par
l'une de leurs députés donc vous voyez
le en même temps on va dire sécuritaire
et migratoire ça fonctionne pas la ville
de Marcq-en-Baroeul chez vous dans le
Nord a décidé d'annuler le concert prévu
design Higelin après ces propos visant
Emmanuel Macron c'est une décision du
maire les républicains vous auriez pris
la même bon moi je souhaite que chaque
mère fasse exactement ce qu'ils veulent
il y a plusieurs choses il y a plusieurs
choses non mais il y a plusieurs choses
qui doivent éclairer une décision bon
d'abord madame Michelin je trouve ces
propos scandaleux je trouve que cette
espèce d'appel allait violence
scandaleux et puis et puis un peu
ridicule permettez-moi de le dire parce
que mon ami Gelin comme tous ces
artistes de gauche morale etc ont appelé
à voter Emmanuel Macron alors maintenant
elle veut le tuer elle veut la battre
etc elle a appelé pour lui donc on est
dans le grand ridicule ça a été mal
interprété sexualiser qu'elle voulait
pas inciter à la violence alors tout le
monde s'en est mieux on a raison de s'en
émouvoir moi je suis contre la violence
en politique on aurait pu s'émouvoir
lorsque le Diam's disait des horreurs
chantaient des horreurs sur Marine Le
Pen ça faisait beaucoup moins réagir
mais je déteste moi ce genre d'appel à
la violence et en cela le maire de
Marcq-en-Baroeul a bien raison de se de
ne pas vouloir que quelqu'un qui pousse
des décrit pareil viennent dans sa ville
au-delà de ça je suis en parallèle très
attaché moi la liberté d'expression et
je pense qu'il y a une loi qui borde la
liberté d'expression qui est connu de
tous et que donc il faut judiciariser
les propos de Madame migelin si elle est
allée au-delà de la loi si elle est
allée au-delà de la loi il faut
poursuivre et puis elle sera sanctionnée
sinon ça veut dire que elle a respecté
la loi et il y a pas de raison d'en
faire toute une polémique donc où les
propos de Madame Higelin sont scandaleux
dépassent le cadre de la loi de la
liberté d'expression et il faut
poursuivre ou alors on considère qu'elle
est juste ridicule et puis se mordra les
doigts elle-même puisque des communes
vont la déprogrammer mon former donc
quand même dans le grand ridicule vous
savez c'est souvent le cas quand ces
grands artistes de gauche moral essaie
de se mêler de politique il tutoie le
ridicule assez vite le ministre
l'éducation nationale papennesia il y a
qualifié Vincent Bolloré de personnages
manifestement très proche de l'extrême
droite la plus radicale et cnews et
Europe 1 il dit qu'ils font du mal à la
démocratie est-ce qu'il est dans son
rôle non parce qu'il sait qu'il est
bientôt dehors donc maintenant après
avoir fait n'importe quoi avec
l'Éducation nationale il dit n'importe
quoi rappelez-vous il y a quelques
propos il y a quelques semaines je crois
que c'est la meilleure culture qui
voulait quand on critique la presse
c'est vraiment un marqueur d'extrême
droite bon bah pas peine critique la
presse visiblement il doit être aussi
dans les yeux de sa collègue d'extrême
droite ces gens-là sa plus ils habitent
ce qui est important c'est la pluralité
dans l'expression médiatique c'est la
capacité à ce qui est des lignes
éditoriales différentes dans une
démocratie cnews comme Europe 1 ont une
ligne éditoriale on adhère on adhère pas
on aime ou on n'aime pas personne n'est
obligé de regarder mais bon de comment
ça la ligne éditoriale
il peut pas y avoir que France Inter qui
n'a que sous un même angle sous une même
j'allais dire philosophique et celle de
dire la présidente de Radio France
disait nous essayons de montrer le monde
tel que nous aimerions qu'il soit pas
tel qu'il est moi je croyais que
lorsqu'on était journaliste on essaie de
décrypter et de montrer le monde tel
qu'il était non elle tel qu'elle
aimerait qu'il soit donc on voit bien
que France Inter a une ligne qui ne fait
réagir personne vous savez lorsque ça me
fait penser au JDD lorsque Nicolas de
Morand passe de France Inter à
Libération ça n'est mieux personne parce
qu'il est de gauche alors tout le monde
trouve ça très bien lorsque c'est
ce pauvre Grégoire le jeune qui passe
Geoffroy Lejeune pardon qui passe au JDD
les journalistes se mobilisent parce
qu'ils ont une conscience probablement
de gauche et qu'il n'accepte pas qu'un
type de droite vient de les diriger tout
ça est ridicule faut de la pluralité
dans la vie il faut de les différences
chacun doit s'exprimer et que papy Andy
s'occupe de son bilan qui est si mauvais
plutôt de la ramener et de commenter ce
que sont les uns et les autres une
question sur les écologistes qui ont
dévoilé leur tête de liste hier pour les
européennes pourquoi est-ce que vous
nous officialisez pas la vôtre
que nous avons eu hier un bureau
politique avec Marine Le Pen et Jordan
Bardella et nous avons acté un
calendrier pour les européennes moi je
souhaite que ce soit Jordan Bardella
mais tout ça sera fait avant la fin de
l'année j'espère qu'il le souhaite aussi
je pense que c'est notre meilleur
candidat
je pense que il y a pas beaucoup de
suspense
Jordan Bardella était à la fois le
meilleur pour mener la campagne il a
déjà démontré c'est le président de
notre parti il a je crois un projet une
philosophie une stratégie pour cette
campagne européenne voilà les choses se
feront j'espère avoir la fin de l'année
avant la fin de l'année oui bien sûr
avant la fin de l'année
prochaine on a quand même un peu le
temps n'est pas en retard la première
candidate a été la candidate écologie si
vous l'avez rappelé ce qui veut dire
d'ailleurs que la nuit pêche n'existe
plus pour les élections européennes ce
qui est bien normal puisque la nuit
pêche c'est un ensemble dans lequel
cohabite des gens qui ne pensent pas
pareil on voit bien que Monsieur Roussel
Monsieur Mélenchon les Verts tous ces
gens là ont une fois l'insulte une fois
qu'ils ont mis de côté les insultes en
fait ils pensent pas grand chose dans
l'ensemble merci merci d'avoir été notre
invité la Une de Ouest-France
c'est à la ligne de votre journal
Stéphane merci Stéphane très bel été à
vous on se retrouve à la rentrée et
merci Sébastien Chenu on passe au club